[Música]
Y cómo avanzaba directo a aquí en
directo a América edición nocturna nos
vamos esta vez hasta Brasil porque el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva se
jugaba su gobernabilidad hoy pues el
congreso eligió a los presidentes de la
cámara de diputados y del senado un
cargo que se renueva cada dos años la
gran pregunta es qué tanta oposición o
respaldo tendrá el mandatario en medio
de la división entre los bolsonaristas y
los aliados de Lula para saber más vamos
a estar Río de Janeiro donde está
nuestra corresponsal Valeria sakone
Buenas noches Valeria qué cambio hubo en
la cámara y cómo hay que entender los
nuevos nombramientos para esta
gobernabilidad de Lula
la reelección de Rodrigo Pacheco en el
senado y de Arthur Lira en el congreso
puede ser interpretada como una victoria
para el presidente Lula y una derrota
para el expresidente Jair bolsonaro de
hecho los analistas políticos hablaban
de tercera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales por la importancia que
tenía hoy esta votación en el primer día
del nuevo ciclo político de Brasil donde
Lula se enfrenta a un parlamento muy
conservador Rodrigo Pacheco al final ha
conseguido 49 votos frente a un Aliado
de bolsonaro mariño es muy importante
porque Pacheco se ha labrado la fama en
los últimos dos años como defensor de la
Democracia ha resistido a las embestidas
de bolsonaro contra las instituciones y
contra las urnas electrónicas y su
reelección representa un nuevo momento
político especialmente tras la invasión
de la plaza de los tres poderes en
Brasilia el pasado 8 de enero ya la
reelección de Arthur Lira en la cámara
de los diputados con 464 votos
representa un esfuerzo de pragmatismo
político porque recordamos
Arthur Lira representa el central el
grupo de partidos de Centro que
tradicionalmente apoyan en cualquier
presidente a cambio de favores políticos
el en la pasada legislatura apoyó a
bolsonaro de hecho fue muy criticado por
no haber dado continuidad a ninguno de
los más de 150 pedidos de impeachment
contra bolsonaro pero ahora Parece que
va a apoyar el nuevo gobierno y de hecho
en la votación curiosamente estaban
juntos tanto el partido de los
trabajadores de Lula como el partido
liberal de bolsonaro
pues Valeria cuéntanos qué más pasó en
la inauguración del año judicial Y
además que dijo el presidente Lula
el presidente Lula también ha discursado
en la apertura del año judicial en la
sede de la Corte Suprema en un acto muy
simbólico porque recordamos que ese
edificio fue el más devastado por los
vándalos Durante los actos
antidemocráticos del 8 de enero de hecho
Lula ha recordado que esos actos no
fueron espontáneos que fueron cultivados
a dicho literalmente por sucesivos
ataques contra la Constitución y Luna ha
prometido mantener una relación cordial
y serena con el poder judicial porque ha
dicho el pueblo está cansado de tanto
conflicto de hecho aprovechado el día
para elogiar el trabajo de la Corte
Suprema sobre todo durante la época de
la pandemia y en la defensa de la
democracia y de las urnas electrónicas
recordamos que tanto bolsonaro como sus
seguidores veían en la Corte Suprema el
mayor peligro porque según ellos
acumulan demasiados poderes pero también
la presidenta del senado reelegido hoy
ha recordado que ahora es el momento de
pacificar y de restablecer unas
relaciones más serenas entre los varios
poderes